[Música]
nossas cidades estão realmente
preparadas para atender os nossos
anseios conta qualidade de vida que
tanto desejamos
talvez seja uma responsabilidade muito
grande pra elas
tendo em vista aqui na verdade a cidade
é um fenômeno muito recente
dentro da história da humanidade as
primeiras cidades surgem há pouco mais
de seis mil anos atrás
hoje nós estamos na era da cidade
contemporânea e como tal essas cidades
estão relacionadas e interligadas entre
si
é o efeito da globalização essas cidades
contemporâneas cumprir um papel
fundamental de conectarmos ao mundo mas
esse efeito tem trazido questões
importantes para nós discutimos o futuro
da nossa humanidade há pouco mais de um
século
nós temos visto transformações antes
nunca vista na história da humanidade no
início do século 20
apenas 10% da nossa população viviam no
meio urbano e na virada do século 21
esse efeito
mudou completamente em apenas cem anos
mais de 50% da nossa população vivem em
cidades
pesquisas demonstram que esse efeito
tende a cada vez mais a crescer e cada
vez mais chega se a cálculos no qual
ainda meados deste século
mais de 75% das pessoas viverão em
cidades é um efeito importante
hoje somos mais de sete bilhões de
habitantes no planeta
pesquisas demonstram que esse
crescimento vem aumentando
gradativamente de forma muito
rápida no qual ainda em meados deste
século
chegaremos à marca de 9 bilhões de
habitantes no nosso planeta como essa
esse crescimento é feito acho que todo
mundo já ouviu falar que a china é o
planeta ou é o país mais populoso do
mundo e um dado importante colocado aí
talvez seja taxa de crescimento da china
percebe que a taxa de crescimento dela é
zero ponto 4% ao ano
tudo bem mas o que nos preocupa hoje
talvez seja além da china é é a índia
que vem crescendo a uma taxa de mais de
1% ao ano
parece um número significativo mas
pesquisas já demonstram que ainda em
meados deste século
esta será a cara do nosso mundo a índia
vai superar a china e número de
habitantes no nosso planeta
essas pessoas nascem e morrem
diariamente em uma conta muito rápida
a gente pode perceber que nasce
efetivamente uma cidade por dia mas
temos um problema colocado aí se nasce
uma cidade por dia
o nosso planeta é um só onde essas
pessoas vão morar onde essas pessoas vão
trabalhar onde as pessoas vão fazer
compras ou ter o seu lazer garantido
junto às suas famílias
esse nosso planeta terra que é muito
mais água precisa ser bem cuidado
nós sabemos que hoje 30% do nosso
planeta é passível de ser ocupado
no entanto desses 30% apenas 3%
efetivamente é ocupado por cidades e com
essa cidade se comporta um caso em cada
cidade vai ter uma
forma de pensar como controlar o seu
desenho como controlar a tal qualidade
do seu território aqui vemos uma imagem
na índia no qual não está muito claro os
seus espaços onde as pessoas andam onde
estão os automóveis ou não outras
cidades por outras formas de se conectar
aos pessoas como por exemplo nova york
que na sua ilha de manhattan
buscou se verticalizar muito mais uma
intenção de conseguir garantir que as
pessoas que moram ali ou trabalham na
ilha tenham a devida qualidade de vida
na capital francesa não buscou essa
mesma alternativa ela se espalhou sobre
o seu território até onde era possível
ainda com uma certa curiosidade porque
paris é muito mais densa é muito mais
ocupada do que nova york então talvez a
solução seja verticalidade outras
cidades vêm trabalhando há mais de um
século na sul no seu planejamento
pensando na tal qualidade de vida e aí a
capital da catalunha barcelona pode ser
um bom exemplo no qual cada quarteirão
de si tem sim buscado uma qualidade de
vida para quem mora ou trabalha naquele
espaço
as cidades na ásia por exemplo com todas
as suas tecnologias vêm se reconstruindo
continuamente e demonstrando a
capacidade que têm de transformação
rápida na busca da tal qualidade e por
que não construímos cidades novas do
bairro foi um fenômeno no mundo no qual
um boom econômico elas apareceu e
transformou a nossa visão de cidade
contemporânea e esse efeito aqui na
américa como ela se dá a gente percebe
que a maioria das nossas cidades
elas foram construídas e ocupadas
de forma não tão planejadas contra tite
almeja de ver a capital do chile do
méxico ou talvez uma cidade na colômbia
como medellín que foi ocupando muito
além do seu território possível e
subindo morros acima até onde era
impossível se ocupar os estados unidos
buscando algumas soluções interessantes
que é construir pequenas cidades ao
longo da costa buscando tal da qualidade
urbana são paulo tem um outro desafio é
a maior cidade da américa latina a maior
economia da américa latina e com essa
cidade pode dar efetivamente a tal
qualidade que todo almeja mas boas
soluções também são possíveis inclusive
no brasil como por exemplo pedra branca
uma cidade fica próximo a florianópolis
que vem colocando em prática
experiências muito interessantes sobre o
aspecto de que a cidade pode sim ser
desenhada para as pessoas enfim todos
nós moramos em algum lugar seja ele no
campo seja ele efetivamente no meio
urbano mas enfim são cidades e onde
devemos mostrar de que forma devemos
mostrar qual essa escolha que nós temos
o qual a cidade que nos oferece a melhor
qualidade de vida que nós tanto
almejamos
mas uma coisa em comum entre todas as
cidades independente onde moramos ou
trabalhamos
nós precisamos nos deslocar de um ponto
a outro
de onde eu moro para o trabalho de onde
moro para onde o estudo de onde eu moro
para onde vou ter um lazer várias
cidades buscaram soluções interessantes
nesse sentido mas no fundo a mobilidade
está sempre direcionada alguma coisa que
não é necessariamente o homem percebe
essa imagem
assim que o espaço destinado ao homem as
pessoas é infinitamente menor do que os
espaços efetivamente de transporte e nós
vamos perdendo a tal qualidade de vida
da cidade
outras cidades buscaram por exemplo
transporte de massa de alta capacidade
como por exemplo são paulo que tem uma
linha de metrô efetiva ainda não atende
à necessidade mas que buscou se uma
alternativa talvez a índia também buscou
alternativas interessante talvez não
tanto sucesso então tal não sabe se o
transporte efetivamente de massa pode
ser uma solução solução então quem sabe
uma solução para o transporte individual
pode ser uma solução bem precisamos nos
deslocar e é nesse sentido que muitos
falam da tal cidade inteligente e eu
sempre pergunto quando vê a cidade
inteligente
quem deve ser inteligente as cidades ou
as pessoas no meu ver a cidade não
precisam ser inteligentes
ao invés de termos cidades inteligentes
que estão ligadas à questão da alta
tecnologia que dispensam recursos e mais
recursos porque não tivemos cidades
criativas no qual as pessoas cumprem um
papel fundamental dentro desse efeito
que o território possa ter em cada
cidade
nesse sentido qualquer cidade pode ser
criativa sem grandes custos se dispensar
de alta tecnologia para se tornar a tal
cidade inteligente e junto a isso talvez
a tal da inteligência territorial seja
um caminho porque no fim a gente não
constrói cidade todos os dias se não
precisaremos construir uma cidade a cada
dia a cidade existem
ela está presente então precisamos dar a
tal qualidade de vida que nós desejamos
para está buscando soluções muito
interessante nesse sentido a partir de
elementos já existentes
antes arquitetônicos o turístico capaz
de gerar uma nova sinergia na cidade
da mesma forma nova york tem uma
proposta de reduzir o número de
automóveis na cidade e coloca um desafio
porque você não pode ir a pé ou de
bicicleta trabalhar ou para a escola etc
no fim o que pode ser muito interessante
é pensarmos sobre uma outra escala a
escala talvez do bairro de onde moro
entender onde eu moro
o que eu tenho próximo a mim se eu posso
fazer uma compra próximo a mim eu posso
ter um lazer eu posso deixar meus filhos
estudando o próximo a mim então os
bairros sim deve ser inteligente nesse
sentido
nesse sentido algumas cidades ensaio
conseguindo fazer isso porque o raio de
abrangência entre tudo o que eu preciso
para ter a tal qualidade de vida começa
a reduzir esse raio muito simples
pesquisas demonstram que qualquer ser
humano
anda tranquilamente 500 metros de
distância
parece pouco né 500 metros são cinco
quadras apenas tenho certeza que muitos
aqui devem dar muito mais que isso mas
se trabalharmos sobre essa lógica
nós teríamos um diâmetro de um
quilômetro
se eu tiver tudo dentro de um quilômetro
que necessito minimamente para viver eu
posso ter ali o que eu almejo como
qualidade de vida à escola o lazer
meus amigos quando eu coloco isso em
tempo eu consigo minimamente em cinco
minutos chegar próximo dos meus amigos
um pouco mais eu e até uma escola ou
outro elemento que eu preciso
então eu consigo andar sobre a minha
cidade e quando eu comecei a andar sobre
a cidade
eu comecei a observar a cidade começa a
perceber coisas que quando
estou às vezes de carro ou de ônibus
talvez isso passe despercebido e começa
a perceber que a cidade pode ser gentil
ela tem se isso a gentileza urbana de
alguma forma talvez com o passar do
tempo essa gentileza foi se perdendo
porque enfim o que equivale para a
cidade hoje o transporte público porque
se mover sobre a cidade a pé foi
perdendo importância mas se resgatar os
isso novamente
isso começa a ter um valor enorme sobre
o efeito da cidade
quando começamos a andar sobre a cidade
percebemos a calçada e bem desenhada
se o mobiliário urbano está colocado
se existe árvore lugar certo se eu
consiga atravessar uma rua mas eu também
posso encontrar os amigos
posso parar para descansar
posso perceber outras atividades que
talvez do meu bairro
no dia a dia eu não percebia a essa
cidade começa a ter vida novamente e aí
a tal da gentileza urbana começa a
renascer novamente e eu posso de alguma
maneira ter tempo pra curtir a minha
cidade e aí talvez toda a cidade pode
ser generosa toda a cidade pode ser
bacana pra se morar
um dado curioso nesse sentido está a de
que em média o brasileiro perde 45 dias
dentro de um transporte público
quarenta e cinco dias ao ano dentro do
transporte público é um mês e meio
bom se eu começar a usar a cidade de uma
forma diferente
eu já ganhei 45 dias ao ano
mas o diu falar o seguinte né olha tempo
e dinheiro
então se tempo e dinheiro quanto custa
esse transporte em média ao ano
para nós brasileiros
é muito rápida podemos economizar 2 mil
reais ao ano
talvez para muitos aqui não faça
diferença mas para uma família que ganha
um salário mínimo
isso pode ter um valor a enorme agregado
à sua renda familiar
mas se tirar essa visão capitalista do
recurso do dinheiro e pensarmos que seu
ganho 45 dias ao ano
na minha vida eu vou ter uma outra coisa
mais importante
eu vou ter a vantagem de se utilizar a
cidade e se essa cidade foi realmente me
dera garantia de que eu possa usar ela
plenamente de uma forma saudável que ela
seja gentil comigo eu comece a ganhar
mais 45 dias para usufruí la como foi
colocado com esse ia conhecer mais
amigos conhecer melhor a minha cidade
esses 45 dias também pode ser mais
saudável porque eu estou caminhando
então também tem uma economia importante
do ponto de vista da saúde
mas enfim quando essa cidade se torna
efetivamente saudável imagem tio eu
ganho uma coisa muito mais valiosa eu
ganho tempo com os meus amigos e com a
minha família e isso não tem preço
obrigado
[Aplausos]